- [Instructor] In the United States today,
we know our system of government so well
that it hardly bears thinking about.
We know that there's a president
who's the head of the Executive Branch,
there's Congress, which is made up
of the House of
Representatives and the Senate,
and there's the judicial branch,
which has the Supreme Court
as its head of a whole court system
that stretches throughout
the United States.
But how did the United States
end up with this system?
We frequently forget that
the Constitutional Convention
which created this system we
know today happened in 1787.
That was more than a decade
after the Declaration of Independence.
So there was this 11-year plus period
before the United States had
its modern day constitution
and during that time, fought
the Revolutionary War,
won in 1783,
and tried out a completely
different system of government
called the Articles of Confederation,
which we talked a little bit
more about in another video.
Now the Articles of Confederation
had a very strong sense
of limited government.
In fact, you could think of
the Articles of Confederation
as being a little bit more
like a loose confederation of states,
where each state had one vote
in the legislative branch,
the branch that makes laws,
and they had to really
agree on most things,
nine out of 13 for most legislation
and unanimous agreement
for any kind of amendments to this system.
And I think it's clear why the founders
first went with this system
of limited government
because they had just
revolted against a monarchy.
They thought of the states as being
in what they call just kind
of a league of friendship,
can almost see it as being similar
to the European Union today,
independent nations who
do some things together
for foreign policy reasons
and economic reasons.
Now by the late 1780s,
it was becoming clear
that the Articles of
Confederation were not working.
With such a weak central government,
it was really hard to get things done.
They couldn't raise taxes.
They couldn't raise a military.
Some states were even putting taxes
on the goods of other states.
So in 1787, delegates
from 12 of the 13 states,
Rhode Island did not
participate because Rhode Island
was not a big fan of central government,
came together in Philadelphia,
in the same place where they had signed
the Declaration of Independence,
to think about how to revise
the Articles of Confederation.
And some very notable figures were there.
George Washington is one of them.
See Ben Franklin over here,
and James Madison.
Although some people that
you might have expected
to be at the Constitutional
Convention were not,
namely, Thomas Jefferson
and John Adams
who were out of the country
being diplomats at the time.
So the delegates at the
Constitutional Convention
have a pretty difficult problem to solve.
They want to have a
stronger central government,
one that can get things done,
make sure the states play well together,
raise armies, raise taxes,
but they don't want a central
government that is too strong
because they just escaped from monarchy.
They don't wanna recreate
monarchy in the United States.
So they're looking for
a very delicate balance
of a government strong
enough to get things done
but not so strong as to promote tyranny.
Now even though the delegates
were supposed to be revising
the Articles of Confederation,
some people had, in secret,
been considering completely throwing out
the Articles of Confederation
and starting anew.
But one of the biggest
hurdles they had to solve
was what would a new sort
of legislature look like.
So the Virginia delegates
suggested a plan for the legislature,
it's the law-making body,
that would be bicameral,
means two room or two house
from bi, meaning two,
and camera, Latin for room.
And their idea was that
there would be a lower house,
similar to the House of
Commons in English Parliament,
that would be directly elected
as individuals would vote
for the representatives
but the number of representatives
that each state would get
would be decided by their population.
Now Virginia was the largest
state by population by far
and so, this plan would have worked out
pretty well for them because
they would have gotten
the largest proportion of representatives.
Small states like Delaware,
and Georgia, Rhode Island,
would have very few representatives
indeed, comparatively.
They also wanted to have an upper house,
similar to the House of Lords
in the British Parliament,
which would be appointed
by state legislatures.
But just like the lower house,
the number representatives
would also be determined by population.
Now as you can imagine, the small sates
were not big fans of having representation
based just on population,
so they came back with a different plan.
This was called the New Jersey Plan.
So the little states said,
"All right, the Virginia Plan
"gives way too much
power to the big states.
"We want an equal voice in legislation."
So the New Jersey Plan,
much like the Articles of Confederation,
gave one vote
to each of the states
so that the small states
would have the same
representation in Congress
as the large states
and their plan was for a single chamber
or unicameral legislature.
So this really wasn't much different
from the Articles of Confederation at all.
So how did the delegates
resolve this issue
of how to balance the
voices of large states
with large populations
with small states that
had small populations?
Because in a situation where all states
have an equal number of votes,
like in the New Jersey Plan,
the 60,000 residents of Delaware
could have as much say
as the almost 700,000
residents of Virginia.
Meaning that the people
who live in Delaware
were in fact more powerful.
But at the same time, you wouldn't want it
so that people living in the larger states
could get their way all the time.
What if the people in Delaware
had a very legitimate concern
that those in Virginia didn't share?
It would be impossible
to get all of these
states to agree, to amend,
or replace the Articles of Confederation
if some of them felt like their interests
aren't being taken into account at all.
So to solve this issue of how to weight
the representation of the states,
the delegates came up
with what's called the Great Compromise
or sometimes the Connecticut Compromise.
And in a way, what they did
was combine these two plans.
They made a legislative branch
that was bicameral, two house,
with a lower and an upper house
and this lower house become
the House of Representatives,
where each state would
have representatives
in proportion to their population.
So states that have large populations
have more representatives.
States with small populations
have fewer representatives.
And those representatives
would be directly elected by the people.
Now, and this time,
the people was a fairly small proportion
to vote in 1790s.
You had to be a white man
with fairly significant property,
so it wasn't full suffrage.
It wasn't event full
suffrage for white men,
but these folks were elected by vote.
And then this upper house
would be the Senate.
And in the Senate, each state
would have two senators,
regardless of their size,
so that as legislation
moved through Congress,
first from the lower house,
where it would be approved
and if approved, sent to the upper house,
there, all states would
have an equal voice
in whether legislation was passed.
And in this upper house,
the senators would not be directly elected
but rather appointed
by state legislatures.
And in fact, senators were
appointed into the 20th century.
Now the Great Compromise
wasn't the only compromise made
at the Constitutional Convention.
They made a number more
and we'll talk more about those
and about the other two
branches of the government
in the next video.